for the last time these are TV specials
and OVA s-- not films all right so over
the last few weeks I've been busy
catching up with it seems literally
everyone else in the community by
watching the classic Dragon Ball films
two of them were good a few of them were
alright in the rest were not so alright
in my opinion however comments that have
come up time and time again had been
asking me to review the specials from
Dragon Ball over the years and I'm
totally okay with taking a break from
these movies to look at some specials
considering some of the films I have yet
to see are some of the lowest rated ones
pray for me so today I will be taking a
look at the history of trunks from 1995
and can't believe I'm saying this Dragon
Ball GT a heroes legacy from 1997 yes
I'm actually gonna look at a Dragon Ball
GT story so let's dive in kicking things
off with the history of trunks I want to
make clear that while I haven't seen
this special I have read accurate
orianna's manga chapter which this
special is based on unsurprisingly where
the anime deviates from the manga is
where I have the most issues with this
version in writing his manga Kiera
Toriyama is intentionally ambiguous in
many areas this serves two purposes
firstly to establish what he needs to in
order to get the story where he wants it
to be as fast as possible and secondly
to not contradict established law as
best he can this is why the fusion
earrings in Dragon Ball super having a
time limit technically isn't a retcon he
left it ambiguous during the Buu saga as
two white Vegeta separated inside Buu
and so when it came time for this during
super while it did rub some people the
wrong way it most definitely wasn't a
contradiction of anything he
definitively established prior and this
can be seen all over his storytelling
throughout the series right it's
revealing that Goku is an alien almost
200 chapters into the series is not a
contradiction of anything he said in the
past he's just giving more information
about Goku's origin that was
intentionally left ambiguous originally
and so ambiguity has been a curatorial
his wisest decision when it comes to his
approach in writing if he doesn't know
what to do he just leaves it blank and
comes back to and wants a credible
excuse or reason to expand upon it comes
to mind because of this practice the
manga chapter largely works perfectly
fine and the TV special is riddled with
plot holes by taking the material of
Akira Toriyama and
pending upon it unnaturally but before I
get into what I didn't like about this
special I want the talk at length about
what I loved first and trust me there's
plenty to love about this story one of
the strongest aspects of it is its use
of consequence without consequences and
storytelling audiences become bored or
detached from the characters and events
that unfold this was Dragon Ball super
his biggest issue for me in many ways in
Dragon Ball Z the Saiyan sagas
consequences lead to the Namek saga and
so on and so forth in Dragon Ball super
each arc sort of stands on its own not
flowing into the next or carrying
consequences of the prior stories events
for it's as if once the arc ends we hit
the reset button but with the history of
trunks this special has more consequence
in it than all of Dragon Ball super in
just 47 minutes
Goku dies and so therefore the rest of
the Z warriors fall which causes the
world to fall into ruin force him go on
to become a stronger hardened warrior
and due to him being the strongest
warrior left he begins training trunks
everything regarding motivation flows
naturally and as a result nothing feels
forced my sympathy is very much there
for Gohan Bulma and trunks as they try
to turn the tide of a losing battle
against two very powerful monsters
speaking of which the androids are
utterly despicable in this story and
their depiction visually only serves to
enhance that fact they're cold dead
stares mixed with a molten hot
destruction they cause makes for some
incredibly unnerving imagery I think
this is best demonstrated during this
scene a scene that is in my opinion the
best of the entire story and funnily
enough it's a combination of
consequences Gohan's choice to go to
lone trunks deciding to search the city
ruins these are all consequences and
every single consequence that has reared
its head in the story culminated with
this magnificent scream from trunks he
learns the truth everything terrible
that has happened to him has been
because of the androids
everything good in his life has come
from two people his mother and his
mentor Gohan a father figure he
desperately needed and just like
everything else in his life it's ripped
away from him
powerless to change anything and it's in
that powerless moment of despair and
misery Trump's uncovers more power than
he ever had before again a consequence
there are so many narrative lis
interesting choices made in this story
that feels so fitting and cathartic to
see Dragon Ball Explorer it's a real
shame the main story didn't embrace
these darker themes more often
but I'm happy that this exists
nevertheless and now that I've told you
why I love this special I'm now gonna be
fair and point out issues I had with it
and one thing that has always bothered
me about it has been how it sort of
ignores something in both the manga and
the anime is version you see Goku dies
at the very beginning causing the world
to spiral into terror under the androids
rule but when has death ever stopped
Goku from communicating or creating a
plan from King Kai's planet to me it
seems really strange that go on hadn't
been in communication with his father at
all and that trunks had never spoken to
him before meeting him in the present
timeline additionally regarding the
anime specifically this time because
they filled out the beginning of trunks
is history with a lot of exposition it
makes me wonder with the military out of
commission and the androids on the tear
across the planet destroying
civilization and humanity you think
people would be a little less casual not
walking around in shorts and t-shirts
caught off guard
not having perfectly thriving businesses
for clothing I mean half the population
is dead why aren't people acting like
half the planet is dead one person even
makes note that because their City is
the last with military presence the
androids won't attack thus everyone
feels comfortable enough to go about
their business at the amusement park
they feel this comfort despite knowing
the androids have destroyed the rest of
the world's military it just doesn't
make sense to me and lastly with my
final gripe this is where the anime
expands upon the manga yet again towards
the end of the story trunks now after
growing up tries to fly and prevent the
androids from causing more damage in
Toriyama's manga it cuts from him
leaving to him at home defeated it's
left to the audience's imagination what
happened to him and how he escaped in
the anime I asked you how does trunks
survive this situation well the fact
remains in this situation they scripted
for themselves no less you shouldn't
have and him doing so makes no sense in
a world that otherwise was grounded in
consequence trunks did something very
stupid and there were no consequences
other than a beating he can heal from
now those small grievances I have aside
I still love this television special and
story I hope I can say the same for the
next one the film begins with one of the
best theme songs ever made
dan dan kokoro he kid ticked q i can't
pronounce it it's a song so infectiously
catchy and nostalgic that it almost
convinces me GT wasn't that terrible
when i hear it with that said right off
the bat i really like the idea of wiping
the slate clean and starting a new would
hundred years in the future after the
events of GT the best part of Dragon
Ball GT and I'm not just saying this as
a joke was it sending an ending that has
genuinely brought me to tears on more
than one occasion that is both uplifting
and tear-jerking all at once
Goku jr. in this film is actually
something of an interesting character
right off the bat throughout the series
the focus has been on the original Goku
he's a character that has always had
things come naturally to him he's
happy-go-lucky and saves the day on a
number of occasions he never worried
about living up to expectations and he
is never worried about recognition even
to his death which is the exact opposite
of this new Goku character things do not
come naturally to him he wants to live
up to this great ancestors namesake and
is constantly second-guessing himself
second-guessing himself funnily enough
in an effort to be more like his
ancestor Goku after the interim prologue
we catch up with Goku jr. as he's
confronted by bullies when leaving
school they push him down stairs mahkum
and steal his things
Goku jr. in response to this does
nothing and when asked why he didn't do
anything by his grandma pan he says this
this is not only weak but is also
something Goku would never have said
himself moreover there being strong
would have been the precise reason for
Goku to act in the first place grandma
pan in response to this begins informing
him on how he should conduct himself
when suddenly she falls to the floor
motionless we cut to a hospital ward
where Goku jr. is telling his grandma
that he won't make his grandma worry
anymore that he'll train hard to beat
these bullies with ease and in a
wonderfully intimate moment of scripting
his grandma goes on to say that true
strength is done about having power but
the ability to look fear in the eye and
do the right thing even when it's hard
to have courage this film so far has
really blown me away and is honestly a
great character study on what makes Goku
Goku his grandma tells him she gave him
the name son Goku because she
knew he was exactly like him when he was
born however full of doubt and concern
Goku jr. begins to cry as pan's
condition worsens faced with the grim
reality that his grandma might not be
long for this world without someone to
lean on and depend on Goku jr. runs off
into the night tears streaming down his
face as far as first acts go this is
honestly exactly what I wanted to see
from Dragon Ball GT the imagery the
motivation and the character is all
there and I odorous back to the story
alone in his room lost for Direction
Goku jr. looks to a photograph of pan
causing him to flash back to when she
told him about the Dragon Balls and how
his great grandpa Goku searched for them
to make a great wish despite it being
well outside of his comfort zone despite
him being terrified Goku jr. decides to
seek the Dragon Balls power to save his
grandma pan Goku jr. in this moment is
courageous answering without hesitation
his call to action armed with this new
mindset he leaves the town in a dominant
fashion passing by his bullies earning
the respect of their leader puck causing
him to join Goku on his journey to Mount
pazu a number of misfortunes befall Goku
jr. as he makes his way to mount POW sue
he confronts his bullies his supplies
are stolen he's attacked by wolves and
even kidnapped by a creature that wants
to eat him however in these moments of
danger something inside this child
awakens freeing him from these dire
circumstances additionally there's a
fantastic scene on a rope bridge that
Goku is terrified to cross as he's
scared of heights his one-time bully but
now companion puck crosses with relative
ease however while Goku himself is
crossing he tells himself that he isn't
scared that is until a strong wind
starts to roar causing the bridge to
break Goku is frozen with fear hanging
on for dear life
puck immediately dashes to Goku's rescue
reaching for his hand unable to gather
the strength to grab his friends hand
the bridge brakes causing Goku to swing
towards the wall and puck to fall to the
depths of the cavern out of sight Goku
just barely manages to scramble to
safety on the other side however there
is no sign of puck Goku jr. is once
again
this is a direct consequence of Goku not
having the courage to trust himself to
grab pucks hand time and time again in
the story Goku jr. is faced with
situation after situation pushing
himself farther and farther outside of
his comfort zone however in these
situations Goku has been forced into
conflict and has never chosen it but
after what happened to puck on account
of his own inaction when faced with
protecting a young bear cub protecting
its mother and defeating the final
villain Goku
despite at first running away decides to
protect everyone from the monster of
Monk Posey for the first time he has put
faith in his own abilities he is being
courageous in conflict and because of
these courageous actions he has saved
everyone now he is free to finally visit
his great grandpa's old home what
follows is the final scene of this story
and early on we learned that Goku jr. is
under the belief that a single Dragon
Ball can grant him the wish that he
desires and so for the duration we are
sort of waiting for this moment of
realization or disappointment and then
this happens now I had never seen this
film I honestly didn't even know it
existed until recently but I want to say
this scene is dare I say it almost
perfect
I absolutely adored this scene and I
loved the message of this short story
and I may have shed a few tears by the
end I'm not gonna lie this was a truly
touching scene and if you haven't seen
this film it's easily worth the watch
why has no one been talking about this
why is this the first time I'm hearing
about this the story is honestly better
than all of the Dragon Ball movies I've
sat in conclusion truthfully despite
having their ups and downs these two
specials were considerably more
enjoyable than the majority of what I've
forced myself to watch with some of the
Dragon Ball films and honestly these
specials from a structuring to pacing to
even run time function exactly as the
fully fledged Dragon Ball films do if
not a lot better the only difference
being they were categorized as TV
specials so if by some miracle you
haven't checked out either one of these
stories you better get on it because
both of these are honestly a fantastic
ride but that'll do it for this week
they
you so much for watching
[Music]